تتعاقب اثار القصف الذي يبلغ دونيات فلا
تحتاج الى ان تذهب بعيدا
عمليه الاصلاح هذه تهدف الى اعاده صيانه
واجهه الفندق الذي نقيم فيه بعد تعرضه
لقذيفه مباشره قبل ثلاثه اشهر خلفت قتلى
وجرحى
[تصفيق]
بعد كل قصف يسارع عمال الصيانه ورجال
الاطفاء والدفاع المدني الى التعامل مع
ماخلفه من اضرار
خلال حالات كثيره عرضه للموت في مدينه لا
يكاد يتوقف عنها القصف
لحسن الحظ لم اكن هنا تصادف القصف مع وجود
زملائي قربه في العمل كانوا خائفين جدا
عملنا يتركز على اصلاح انابيب الغاز
والكهرباء وتلك مهام صعبه جدا في دنيتك مع
سنن نفعل نريد ان نعيش
فقد العشرات حياتهم او اصيبوا خلال ادائ
هذه المهام وهي مهام تتوقف عليها حياه
سكان مدينه كان يعيش فيها نحو مليون نسمه
قبل تسعه اعوام
فهجرها قرابه 80 في المئه منهم
الوضع في المدينه صعب
بشكل منتظم ويستهدفون كل شيء بما فيه
البنيه التحتيه خمسه احياء تحت القصف
اليوم اوكرانيا اغلقت قناه سفيرسكي وهي
مصدر المياه الوحيد للمدينه
يقول الموالون لروسيا ان هدفهم هو السيطره
على المناطق المتاخمه للمدينه للحول دون
ان تنال نيران القوات الاوكرانيه دونيتك
معقلهم الاساسيه في اقليم دمباز يطول امه
هذه الحرب وتزداد معه صعوبه الحياه هنا في
دنياك فلا يكاد يمر دون ان يطلها القصف
واقع ليس وليد الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
الماضي بل قبل ذلك بنحو ثمانيه